what of this video playing freedom us a
new coach r ball from Australia that I
played before no I didn't very high rate
it 25 something as provide a lot in five
minutes yeah one of my pet alliance
against the Kings Indian the h3
variation yeah like normally play some
v6 but he didn't you went from benoni
without the upon moving ok we can you
can still go back play 60 m or something
like that I can I don't really think
that this is too great but interesting
that's an interesting way to play to to
wait until I'm committed to short
castles and then play 50 so okay so the
question is do I have play on the
queenside only or do I am take only six
this is actually an idea to take him
because he's got the lights and not
particularly well placed for exploiting
the d4 hole okay but still play on the
queenside
he needs prep moves to get a 5 going F
595 should be good should be maybe not
clear-cut but ok so he's opening up the
queenside strangely enough I was I
wasn't really one hundred percent sure
how I should open up the queenside ok so
how do you play him his maybe playing
even a five not that's not completely
completely crazy
ok we will play at five and nine f6 I
can still keep this I really wonder if a
plane fly groupie one really play a five
yeah he may be will yeah this of course
has weakened the dark squares but is it
a delight schools I'm sorry but how
dangerous is it for four black yeah
difficult to say this I didn't expect
so he's so really shoving the night over
here hmm yeah okay well it's interesting
he's not quickly with pushing at five he
just wants to defend the queenside first
I still don't mind that too much
hirokazu of my my activity against the D
676 pawn I came go here now let's see
it's not so easy to continue here
admittedly okay to okay one maybe maybe
I should have taken on a eight first
okay
okay let's push this i okayed not
playing very sloppily here not really
exploiting things to the max I mean not
like I'm winning if I'd play better but
I'm just giving him things that I think
I shouldn't give him okay it's still
nothing terrible happened I could have
taken at five actually hey I need a come
on I need to think here I'm playing this
too quickly that five was just I could
have just taken that fine I Scotty for
ok ok ok ok so this was actually ok but
still I should have considered the move
it takes now I take with the bishop I
think I'm perfectly a ride if he takes
Queen eat or get the porn back
okay so he's just closing closing this
let's scrap here and now try to get to
the large scale wait i could play i can
i can actually play a look here i should
do that really I got the chance I should
do that I don't really think f3s is
dangerous here
k okay wants to go Queen 87 ham and rook
a4ai sub I guess pointless okay let's
just take play here ideas to go Queenie
to and try to do something on the light
squares
okay I don't mind that too much really
he cannot do much with the bishop in
time morning I mean even if you get the
Bishop to g5 this is not much happening
really ok Toby six is not doing much I
can just stay put here
between H a check mark check threatening
age for checkmate what is it doing
against that each for Queen edge was
also made I just ran into a self-made
that's made next move really have no
check yeah lack reason he avoided all
kinds of drawers to try to win but it
was just a suicidal here it's just equal
I mean you can play whatever this is
still ok and here just Bishop f6 okay
I'm done playing without this Bishop so
it's not like i have an attack with the
Queen only the computer gives an
interesting line here though it wants to
delay f form takes not necessary and
then e five intending be should be three
this does seems to be a draw according
to the computer now there's some some
ways like that to try to to get some
live into the position but it's
basically just the draw yeah here g3 the
computer recommends III I couldn't I
couldn't really bring myself to play
that but probably f3 is just weak yeah
the computer gives says that that I'm
just good I'm just doing the pawn yeah
okay maybe I should have invested a
moment I was just thinking that if I if
I get this position and get the Queen
activated here I should be quite safe
and can play quick moves I was down fall
down by almost a minute so it was
valuable to have some easy move
to play yeah it should have been a droid
just played too hard for win alright
thanks for watching